This homework is to play the word game Boggle.
Now, Boggle is played with a set of letters that are arranged into an n x n grid--here 4 x 4--
but you should accept other size as well, and your task is to find all the words
that can be found in this grid.
Now, you can simply take ones across, so PLAY would be a word.
They don't have to go all the way across.
So LAY would be a word as well.
They can turn corners and go in any direction.
Starting at T we could go T-O-W.
We can continue from there T-O-W-A-R-D-S,
and in general we can go to any adjacent square horizontally, vertically, or diagonally.
We can't duplicate, so H-I-S is a word, but we can't do H-I-S-S,
because S is not a neighbor of S--so HIS but not HISS.
We could do S-I-R, but not S-I-R-S, because each letter can be used only once.
We can't come back and repeat on ourselves.
Now I'm going to ask you to write the function bogglewords(),
which takes as input a representation of the board, like this,
and a minimum length of the words that count.
Three-letter words at least. Two-letter words don't count, so don't both returning them.
It returns a set of words, which again are taken out of our WORDS dictionary.
Now, because I'm going to pass in the board, I have to give you the representation for that.
I'm going to make a slightly different choice than I did for Scrabble boards,
just to show you the range of options we have for representing two-dimensional objects like this.
Now, we're trying to represent this two-dimensional array,
and in Scrabble we chose a representation like this--a nested list of lists.
If we assign board to this list, then we can access an element with two integers subscripts like that.
In our representation of Scrabble, we also made a small change
so that we didn't have to worry about going off the board,
which is that we introduced these border markers--
the vertical bars to mean a boarder at the ends of every row,
and we also had a top row and a bottom row which consisted entirely of bordres.
It's as if we took this game here, and we just extended it by making a border all the way around.
This 2D representation would work fine in the Boggle case,
but I just want to show you another possibility,
which is a one-dimensional representation where instead of saying board[ j ][ i ] for position
we only have to say board[ i ], and we get that representation just by concatenating together
all the elements.
We take all the elements in the first row and then add onto that list
all the elements in the second row, all the elements in the third, and so on.
Now we have a one-dimensional array. Why is that better?
Why is it better to have a one-dimensional array
to represent an inherently two-dimensional object? Seems like a step backwards.
Well, one thing is that now we can have a position in the array represented by
a single object, by an integer, rather than by a pair of integers
that have to be broken up to subscript into the board. That's one advantage.
Secondly, it's easier to enumerate over them.
We can just say "for (i, s) in enumerate(board)"--remember enumerate takes
a sequence and returns the elements of the sequence in turn.
That would be the s's--the contents of each square, which would be the letters like P and L.
And also an index into them--the integer i, which would be a integer 0, 1, 2, and so on.
It's easier to enumerate over the entire board in this 1D representation
rather than in the 2D.
Both representations work fine, but I wanted to give you a little experience using this alternative.
Let's do an example of this representation.
Here's a simple board. It looks like that.
Now we want to add on border cells, so we'll do that all around. It looks like that.
Now, we just put that together into a string,
and so the final string would look like this.
Now, in terms of the indexes into the array,
right here would be index number 0,
and we could just enumerate them out.
Since it's a 5 x 5 array, the indices go from 0 to 24.
Now, let's say we want to find all the neighbors of this central square, the W.
So the neighbors would include basically all the letters here would be a neighbor of W.
The index of W is 12.
If we say that the length of a side of this matrix--we'll call that N--is equal to 5,
now we want to know all the neighbors of a cell.
Let's say we're looking for the neighbors of i = 12,
then it's 6, 7, 8, 11, 13, 16, 17, 18.
Here is i--11 and 13 are easy. That's i - 1 and i + 1.
The 7 is just i - N. The 17 is i + N. Then you can fill in the others.
You see starting from i, it's easy to generate
the eight neighbors just by adding and subtracting Ns and 1s.
It's a little bit simpler doing it this way than it would with the two-dimensional representation.
Here's what I'm asking you to write--this function bogglewords()
given a board and a minimum length for each of the words returns a set of words.
Here are some test  for you.
First the board function, and I've written that so don't worry about it. We'll see it below.
Here's a simple test--not many words you can find in there.
That should be the whole set.
I've defined for you a function neighbors, which takes a square location--
square number 20 in a 6 x 6 board--and tells you want the neighbors are.
Then here's an example of playing this word game.
Here's the set of answers, and for this bigger board with more letters on it,
there is 317 words in our small dictionary that was found.
Here's our representation of board, using the single string representation that I talked about.
Here's a simple function to display that.
It doesn't actually print it, but returns a string, which is easily printable.
Then this part--the words and prefixes--you might find very useful.
That's unchanged from before.